yo what's up Sammy leaves here and on
this video I wanted to tell you exactly
what is rent arounds so if you've been
wondering and hearing the term rent to
rent and not know exactly what it is in
this video I'm going to explain what it
is I'm also going to show you how if you
understand how to use this strategy of
rent to rent how you can make serious
cash flow every single month starting
with very little effectively Reptar end
is when you rent a property off a
landlord and usually it will be a
reasonably low rent it will be off a
particular type of landlord and a
particular type of properties doesn't
work on every house and with every
landlord
so let me pre-qualified firstly the line
look the landlord it has to be a
landlord who is happy to receive a low
guaranteed rent so he can't be a
landlord that was as much as he can
possibly get every single month and he's
looking to really no it needs to be
someone who's more hands-off that just
wants a quiet life no hassle and he
wants a guaranteed rent that needs to be
the qualification of the landlord the
qualification of a house needs to be
that the house can achieve a lot more
rent than it is currently doing so what
kind of house would that be well there
can be different types of examples one
might be it could be that the house is a
big house and it's being rented out and
it could be rented out in two different
separate units so that could be a hey
cello for example this is the most
popular type of rent to rent so you've
got a five bed house the landlord is
renting the whole thing out for six
hundred pounds a month and it's near a
city center and you think hmmm he's
renting it was six hundred per month for
the whole house but if I came in and
just furnished the property made it a
bit prettier maybe paid for the all the
utility bills which might cost me a few
hundred pound a month I could then re
rent out the rooms for four hundred
pound a month which would be
considerably more profitable so needs to
be a house where you could increase the
rent another example would be maybe it's
just a little studio apartment in a city
centre and it's renting out for five
hundred-pound a month this little studio
apartment you could think that little
studio apartment
a little bit of creativity if I was to
put a key safe outside the apartment and
was to furnish it and include the bells
I could rent that out as a hotel like a
hotel without staff I could list this
property on Airbnb in booking.com and
instead of getting maybe five hundred
pounds a month I could get five hundred
pound every few days in rent from guests
so you can massively raise the rent on
that so if you can find a property where
you can massively raise the rent and
then a landlord who just wants a nice
simple guaranteed rent he doesn't want
to mess around maybe he's old school
isn't what like risks he hasn't got the
inclination he hasn't got the time he
might not even have the few thousand
pounds of money to put it in the way
that leads to bay you can find those two
people together that's when you can do a
rent around and effectively all you'll
do is you'll just offer to give the
landlord and guaranteed rents where you
know and the key to this is always you
know it's always a bet down to your
knowledge it's always down to your due
diligence and you being able to be the
smart person in the game that can give
the landlord what he wants can change
the properties used to make a to push
the rents up and then of course you in
the middle keep the difference so you'll
give the land of what he wants you'll
rent the property up for more and then
you'll keep the difference now all I
wouldn't suggest doing the RIP to rent
unless the difference is at least five
hundred pounds a month so because it's
not worth the hassle if you're messing
around secure the deal with the landlord
then you and you're gonna make to Japan
a month I don't think it's worth the
hassle so I'll be saying at least five
hundred pound now some of my properties
and some of my students and you can you
can check up on the other videos but
some of my students have got rent to
rent where they're making a thousand
pounds plus per rental rent property and
they've paid practically nothing to do
this and to secure these types of deals
so that's what went to rent is how are
you going to find these types of rent to
rents well you can find these agents
from networking you can find them online
you can find them through agents you
seem to find the right kind of property
the right kind of landlord where you can
offer that sort of deal that is rent to
rent very very popular strategy here in
the UK at the moment
very low entry point you don't need any
qualifications to do a renter and you
don't need a lot of money again I've got
students that have come into this
country with nothing and then to do rent
events within the literally a few months
you do need to actually do properly so
you're going to need a proper agreement
the type of agreement you're gonna need
is you're going to need a corporate let
management agreement so you can't do
this with just normal SPS some people
say you know oh is this illegal it's
illegal when you do it wrong on the
wrong contracts then it'll be custer
subletting when you do rent to rent
legally it's completely aboveboard it's
something that even we've got solicitors
who are in our academy and they're doing
this strategy we've got estate agents
doing this strategy so hopefully that's
kind of clear at what rent to rent is if
you've got any questions about renter
ain't welcome below in the comments and
maybe I'll do a more detailed video
answering your questions and please
don't forget to subscribe share and like
this video
really appreciate all of your success is
my oxygen so I'm going to keep doing
these videos until you keep becoming
successful let me know when that happens
god bless
[Music]
you